[Musique]
car ils vont se faire plaisir il est
légal ah
ok il fait une chose pareille
[Musique]
ma démarche est personnelle j'estime que
je dois l'imposer à personne du coup ma
chérie je sers la cuisse comme
d'habitude
du coup je mange prie les jambes mais
puisque te dis que c'est une démarche
personnelle oui mais justement si elle
mange de la viande et qu'après mon bras
c'est comme si j'en mangeais donc elle
nui à ma démarche personnelle je suis
sur 17 du coup non une zone de contact
énorme avec le poulet sa fille joy radio
hier
à vos démarches personnelles c'est sa
voix la saphir
j'ai dit ça je peux uniquement du vin
vegan pour le raisin est broyé c'est le
sens des moustiques des moucherons des
limaces des escargots
voyez vous ce que vous appelez le
château saint-émilion moi j'appelle ça
du château de weeds
alors oui mais dans les gâteaux et des
oeufs je vous dis que la poule n'a pas
un attachement à son oeuf vous diriez
quoi ou si chaque matin vous vous voulez
un autre
enfin merci j'avais remarqué mes raisons
plus en fait croyez qu on en fait quoi
des vaches laitières dans votre cas qui
donnent plus de lait
le café était délicieux remercie ses
cauchemars habille toi on y va on va
faire une démarche personnelle
[Musique]